live stream but anything is possible it
may not be live uh we are waiting close
looks like you're ready go live
okay
here we go all right we are live with
sir Roger Penrose and with Stuart
hammeroff joining us from various
locations around the world uh and
hopefully everyone out there will enjoy
this wide-ranging uh conversation on
Consciousness the brain quantum
mechanics and controversy or controversy
as we say uh and that has to do with
some recent developments both
experimentally and in the world of the
theory basis for what is called orc or
which we'll talk about but first a very
important announcement I want to wish a
happy 91st birthday to Sir Roger Penrose
Roger how do you how does it feel to be
91 to reach midlife
what's the date
well I think uh it's the fifth fifth of
August no I've got I've got three days
to go so three days okay so three days
of being in the 90 only 90 yes but
you're in me the 91st year
um and Stuart you are joining us from
where
Banff in Canada where I've been
attending a workshop uh related to the
experiments we did from a Templeton
Grant to test uh orcolar looking at
Quantum effects and microtubules and
Roger uh zoomed in uh all week and gave
an excellent talk also Ah that's fun uh
fantastic and there's been a lot of news
and Stuart I've meant to have you on uh
for a long time and uh this is kind of a
special treat to have both you guys on
at the same time and and really the
occasion is this uh dramatically kind of
progressing field of Consciousness in
fact just last week Roger your ears were
probably burning because we had a a live
webinar with some friends in the UK and
around the world that I hosted for the
institute for art and ideas and the
question was about reality and the role
that quantum mechanics plays and quite
frequently we invoked your name in fact
we said many times we asked Eric weinst
Stein Sabina hasenfelder Carlo ravelli
all PhD theoretical physicist we asked
them to comment on your comment uh as
you have said in the past that
Consciousness reeks of something quantum
mechanical so I want to ask you Roger
um first of all how when you think about
the role of quantum mechanics that you
learn from Dirac and that you taught at
least to me the first time in the
emperor's new mind 30 plus years ago has
your how is your thinking evolved on
quantum mechanics and its role in
Consciousness if at all
well there is an important development
which has happened I guess I mean a lot
of things are very similar to what I
thought in the emperor's new mind the
the ideas I put forward there
um and I should point out you see people
often regarded his as uh
very revolutionary or something like
quantum mechanics could be involved in
consciousness
but the point is that my view is that
it's even worse than that in that it's
not quantum mechanics being involved
it's where quantum mechanics is
incomplete or or even not quite correct
because quantum mechanics has a big
puzzle right as its roots
and some people can't resolve this by
invoking Consciousness in the sort of
opposite way that I do
you see the question is
there's a thing called the Schrodinger
equation which tells you how the quantum
State evolves in time
and this is an equation which is very
deterministic just like Newtonian
mechanics and that sort of thing so if
you know what the state is now it will
tell you what the state will be in 15
minutes from now and so on the only
trouble is that it doesn't because uh it
only tells you what the quantum state is
and the quantum state
um you make measurements in order to
find out or what the thing tells you and
to make a measurement you have to
involve something else that's not part
of the system you sort of wheel the
measuring device out of the cupboard and
get it to measure the state and then you
wheel it back into the covers again and
the trouble is that if you were
consistent you'd have to consider that
that machine you just moved out of the
cupboard is also following the
Schrodinger equation and if you do that
you get nonsense you don't get one
answer to your questions you get a
what's called a superposition of
different alternative answers if you
want to get one answer you've got to do
standard quantum mechanics what's called
making a measurement and what's called
making a measurement involves violating
the schroding equation now showing was
absolutely clear on this that he was one
of the people who was completely clear
and that's why he considered this
thought experiment of a cat in the box
and you put this card through under this
superposition of being dead and alive
and schroding and we say look this is
ridiculous you couldn't have a cat
that's dead and alive but lots of people
say oh we'll have to try and make a
machine which actually makes a cat dead
and alive
what schroding was pointing out that
quantum mechanics as understood in other
words following his equation gives you
nonsense it tells you that you have cats
that are dead and alive at the same time
now some people would take a view they
would in the early days of quantum
mechanics
that you need a conscious Observer to
come along
and it's the conscious Observer who
looks at the quantum State and that
makes it be one thing or another rather
than both things at once
now that's ridiculous in a way and I
don't want to go anywhere it's
ridiculous but it was very strongly held
by quite a lot of very distinguished
physicists in the in at the time now is
the view I hold is almost the opposite
of that it is that the state does reduce
itself that is to say the cat becomes
either dead or alive spontaneously not
because anybody looks at it or even the
cat losing it itself
but because this superposition is too
big in a certain sense and that it
spontaneously becomes one or the other
and it has in it and it does this with
something much much smaller than the
size of a cat it's a very tiny effect
which could make it go come one or the
other
and this involves in my view
um bringing the general theory of
relativity in Mrs Einstein's theory of
gravity curved space time and all that
sort of thing and when you bring this
into Quantum mechanic you find that you
have a conundrum and the way out of way
of resolving this conundrum is to say
that instead of having these
superpositions at two things at once
there was a certain lifetime of that
seasonal position and the bigger the
season position is the shorter the
lifetime is so whether if it was a cat
Dead or Alive it would be virtually
instantaneous but you can't couldn't
have something very much much smaller
than that and it becomes one or the
other
in a time that you can calculate and the
idea that Stuart and I have been trying
to develop is that in the brain or
primarily in things like microtubules or
big collections of microtubules probably
that it's that's where one thing or the
other thing happens and the process of
one thing or the other thing happening
well that's what we we refer to as as
proto-consciousness
the proto-consciousness is sort of the
building block out of which
Consciousness is built so the reduction
of the state as I say they were the
quantum State choosing one or the other
rather than both at once that process
is something outside standard quantum
mechanics but it's something which you
can make predictions about if you bring
Einstein's general theories of
Relativity into the picture and it gives
you a time scale
for how long the superposition can exist
before one or the other happens the
claim we make is that each time this
choice of whether one thing or the other
happens that's what we call
proto-consciousness and as I say it's
the building block out of which actual
Consciousness which is involves many
many of such processes
actual Consciousness comes about so
that's a sort of summary of our point of
view except in detail what's going on
which is Stuart have much better ideas
about that than I do so right yeah so
and Stuart this the conference that
you've been at um involves some kind of
uh orchestration as well because you've
been talking about uh how we can
identify experimentally where
Consciousness might take place and I
wonder if you could kind of give an a
slight overview maybe a recap for the
audience that might not be as familiar
as as I am but um I said in a tweet I
put out you know that sir Rogers book
The Emperor's New mind really influenced
me it was the first popular science book
I ever read as a 15 year old and uh then
I was tickled when he endorsed my my
book uh losing the Nobel Prize my first
book which allowed him still to go on
and win the Nobel Prize a few years
later despite his association with with
yours truly
um but he said yeah he was disappointed
in that book because at the end you know
he kind of speculates and he was hoping
that he'd get some fresh young people
and with new ideas Etc and he got well
you were young I mean you're not that
old now so so you couldn't have been
that all 30 years ago
he's remaining ill retired people who
cut hold of me there were a few younger
people and and Stuart was one of the
younger people so what jumped out at you
about that book uh that caused you to
take the risk and and and start this
relationship with Roger that's persisted
for the last 30 plus years
right well I had uh at that point uh in
the early 90s when I read it I've been
studying microtubules inside cells
particularly inside brain neurons I had
I got interested in microtubules in
medical school and studying uh mitosis
in a cancer lab where the these mitotic
spindles which are microtubules pull
apart the chromosomes in a very highly
orchestrated dance to get exact
separation of uh duplicate pairs of
chromosomes that go on to each becomes
the daughter cell and if that isn't
perfect then you get uh you can get a
cancer you can get Mal development and
so forth and so everybody else in the
lab got really interested in the
chromosomes being the dawn of the
genetic uh Revolution and so forth in
the early 70s but for some reason I got
fascinated with these structures which
seemed to know where to go and what to
do it seemed to have some kind of
intelligence and I had been interested
in Consciousness for my undergraduate
days and so I wondered whether these
structures which turned out to be
microtubules might be processing
information and I was primarily
interested in the brain and
thought that they might support
processes inside neurons leading to
Consciousness because if you think about
the neuron as a simple on off switch as
most people do the brain is a complex
computer of simple neurons then you
treat each neuron as a one or a zero but
actually if you think of a single cell
organism like a paramecium it swims
around it finds food it finds a mate it
has sex it can learn it's very clever it
doesn't it I'm not saying it's conscious
necessarily although it might be but it
has Intelligence and it uses its
microtubules so at that time the
structure of microtubules was discovered
to be a lattice a cylindrical lattice
with in some cases Fibonacci geometry
and I spent a number of years
looking at information processing models
in microtubules as basically a molecular
scale computers which increase the
information capacity inside neurons
tremendously about a billion tubulins
switching at 10 megahertz gave you 10 to
the 16th operations per second per
neuron whereas neural net people AI
people The Singularity people were
saying no there were 10 to the 16th
operations per second in the entire
brain and when that was met we have
brain equivalence and Consciousness and
I was going around being a pain in the
rear end to AI people saying no your
your Target's way way Downstream you're
being naive and insulting the neuron by
saying it's a one or a zero and they
would say things like go away Kid you
bother me you know what do you know and
uh and and but then one day somebody
said something very very important and
profound to me he said let's say you're
right how would that explain
Consciousness you have all this
information processing at a deeper level
and you have 10 to the 27 instead of 10
to the 16th operations per second how
would that explain feelings love joy
emotion the color pink and I had to
admit I didn't know and I was a bit
stunned to be categorized as a
reductionist but that's what I was but
fortunately that person suggested read
Roger's book The Emperor's New mind
which I did and I was really fascinated
and Blown Away by it the bottom line
being that he had a mechanism for
Consciousness and nobody else did before
everybody else it's it's or even still
today kind of hand-waving arguments
about complexity emergence uh maybe it's
fundamental maybe it's pan psychism but
you know who knows but he had a specific
mechanism which at the time I didn't
understand and still don't completely
understand but I've I've certainly
studied and pondered it for many years
and so I thought you know in the end of
his book he said well we need a quantum
computer in the brain that will Collapse
by his or mechanisms and uh he was he
mentioned that you know neurons exons
firing and not firing that superposition
it was it was too large scale and I
agreed and I wrote to him and I told him
about microtubules and that they might
be the quantum computer collapsing by
his objective reduction that he was
looking for and uh he uh he agreed
enough to uh so that we met in his
office I happened to be going to England
and uh I told him about microtubules and
he appreciated very much and that
started our collaboration
and when you know most people think
about quantum mechanics and I said you
know I love you guys and and uh you've
uh you've all been generous with uh with
your time and and conversing with the
public but you know today's not just
purely a Love Fest because uh we just
found out it's not Roger's actual
birthday so we we can ask uh you know
does the emperor have clothes and what
is the most common objection sir Roger
what do people say I know what I think
as an objection but you know I'm not as
erudite uh in this field as most people
what's the most common objection and
what do you think is the best objection
to orc or if any
maybe maybe the best objection was my
own objection at the time which was when
I wrote the empress new mind I could see
no way I might try to learn about nerve
propagation and I learned about the
Hodgkin that's the problem you know and
all this kind of stuff which is the
official way in which signals the sense
around the brain and I hope there's no
hope you see I thought by the time I
learned these things I would finish off
my book with a great Dash and say this
is how you explain Quantum Consciousness
and I I couldn't it just didn't make any
sense to me and so I kind of petered off
with not really knowing what I was doing
and then I got this
letter from this unknown person to me uh
Stuart hammeroff I get lots of crazy
letters from people who says is this
another crazy letter what are these
funny little tubes he's talking about
I've never heard of them before when I
look them up after that if I'm going my
gosh it's right and so I communicated
with him and we got together and this
was the first time I could see a route
to something where you could possibly
you see me you hate you what you need in
order to to for this kind of scheme to
work you need
um
some isolation so you can get your
Quantum degrees of freedom don't get
sort of spread out through the brain as
it would be if it was just nerve
propagation then there are these
electromagnetic fields which spread out
and they they simply do what's called
Deacon here Deco here and the and you
just lose everything so you need
something
which has the hope of of preserving
these degrees of freedom these quantum
mechanical degrees of freedom and the
macrotubules look to me the best thing
I'd ever seen
as a possibility for doing this I think
we we still have to work hard to and I
think it's they're not any of my
microtubules that they have to be
organized right and they have to do
something like uh
well I knew about the
and I knew various things about the
brain for example with the cerebellum
which has because I now know more micro
more neurons in it than the cerebrum I
didn't know at the time I think they
didn't have the numbers right then but
now certainly they were comparable
whereas the cerebrum were
CR sort of
conscious thoughts seem to be connected
with the cerebellum it seems to be
pretty well unconscious yet it's got all
these neurons and why are they not being
conscious right
right who comes up with no what I think
is a much better understanding of what
the difference could be and that is
these cells called pyramidal cells which
are simply not present in the cerebellum
and this is the first time I've heard of
something where you see a key difference
and where the cerebellum
it doesn't have these things and and
that would explain why it's not
conscious and
perfectly you know when I see people
objecting to Orco are uh Etc it's it's
and the objection that while quantum
mechanical effects you know don't take
place at room temperature inside of a
squishy wet environments uh etc etc and
I wonder you know Stuart uh what what
objections and you're not a Quantum
physicist you're not a physicist at all
you're an anesthesiologist with a deep
and abiding interest and Fascination and
these topics but the question I have you
know is how um was it a solution in
search of of a problem in other words
you know could have been any other cell
what is unique about microtubules and
how can they persist not decohere at
room temperature inside a wet squishy
environment
right everybody said well obviously the
brain is too warm wet and noisy for uh
delicate Quantum effects they would
decohere but the brain is not a
homogeneous monolithic material the
brain is highly heterogeneous and this
occurs in various ways different uh and
anatomical reasons as Roger just said
but as an anesthesiologist or a
pharmacologist and we're kind of Applied
pharmacologists we think about where
drugs go and how they act and the the
the body the brain has different
compartments of solubility so for
example most drugs that you you either
taking a pill or IV IM however you take
it wind up uh does binding in an area
that fits their solubility so most drugs
are polar that is they have charges they
are soluble in water and they bind to
charged uh receptors usually on the on
the surface of cells anesthetics are
completely different they are nonpolar
they are hydrophobic they avoid they go
to places where water doesn't go uh it's
oil and water don't mix okay so that's
basically the idea and uh there's a a
pretty good percentage of the brain and
body in general that is nonpolar that is
hydrophobic that is comprised largely of
for example aromatic Rings like Benzene
which is you know gasoline if it's in
bulk form but in individual uh molecules
it can have very delicate Quantum
effects and all the psychoactive
molecules uh serotonin dopamine the
psychedelics are are composed of these
aromatic Rings which have high electron
resonance States so and these Pi
electron resonance States they fluoresce
they luminesce they do all kinds of
things that are basically Quantum
Optical effects and and the anesthetic
and they tend to these uh amino acids
that have these Rings tend to coalesce
inside proteins and that's where the
anesthetics go they bind in these uh
nonpolar hydrophobic regions uh which
we've come to call the quantum
underground by the way because that's
where the quantum stuff happens they it
forms a decoherence free Subspace with
limited degrees of freedom uh that is
very conducive to to Quantum effects and
in fact uh We've shown this and um so
that's what the the anesthetics go and
they bind only by very weak Quantum
forces so you have uh molecules that are
otherwise inert even the inert gas Xenon
is an anesthetic that goes to these uh
uh places in the brain that have these
nonpolar uh Pi resonance ring uh rings
and they uh in fact they bind all over
the body in fat stores there's more
anesthetic in a patient's rear end than
in their brain but obviously it works in
the brain just like there's a lot of
anesthetic in the membranes and lipids
uh in the in the brain or the fat around
the body and but that's not where they
work all they all they do primarily is
affect Consciousness they have uh very
very few other other side effects
they're fairly selective and specific
and these are ubiquitous right Stuart
these are exist in all animals uh you
know so
yes yes top brains right they're yes but
they're arranged in a particular way in
the pyramidal cells uh that that I'll
come back to but um so there's this
hydrophobic region the anesthetics bind
by Vander by Quantum forces Van Der
waals forces so you have this strange
situation where these molecules go all
over the body and uh bind by these uh
Quantum forces everywhere and yet all
they do is affect Consciousness and what
that says to me is that Consciousness
involves highly organized highly
coordinated orchestrated delicate
Quantum processes that are easily
interrupted if if the anesthetics go
into the fat of somebody's fat store
somewhere there's no Quant there's no
organized Quantum stuff going on so
there's no effect so it suggests that
and that uh Consciousness depends on
highly organized orchestrated Quantum
effects and in fact that's what we've
been talking about all week at this
conference because uh we got funded from
Templeton as I said and we've been doing
experiments in two different Labs
looking at Quantum Optical effects in
microtubules and then showing that those
effects go away with anesthesia
and uh Roger this uh Quantum object you
said you were surprised that these
microtubules existed and they seem to be
designed
um when I think about quantum mechanics
uh you know typically yes there are
collapsing wave functions or
superpositioned States but do you think
we could even have a theory of
Consciousness that is quantum mechanical
before we solve something like the
measurement problem or do you think that
that is not necessary as a precondition
I would think it's the wrong way around
that is to say
I mean I think that we're not going to
put it like this I don't think we're
going to have a theory of Consciousness
until we have a theory of State
reduction that is the collapse of the
wave function now that whatever you call
it
um
whether we will have one then I don't
know but uh I think that's another step
you see we still don't understand
why or how the wave function collapses
in any detail I mean there are schemes
about this and one of these
um is is my own but that's we lots of
people have different views on this it's
certainly and lots of people don't even
believe it you see lots of people
haven't thought it through they think
somehow you don't need a new theory in
quantum mechanics I don't quite know why
they they ignore the collapse of the
wave it's called collapse of the wave
function you know the wave function is
supposed to chug along according to this
radio equation then suddenly it
collapses and this is known right from
the beginning and it schroding a
with his introduction of this
theoretical story about the cat so he
was obviously very worried about that
phenomenon so it's there
but people were very fuzzy about this
kind of thing
uh
Stuart are you still there
no we seem to have lost our guests for
some reason
see if we can bring them back in
that's very strange
uh let's see here if I can figure out
what is going on
um
yeah it is strange they just disappeared
um hopefully they'll come back on
and we will regain Consciousness in the
Stream
because what I'm really hoping to do is
to get a distinction we heard sir Roger
just talking about collapse of the wave
function there are theories that don't
involve collapsing wave functions such
as uh everettian many worlds
interpretations and so
um I want to uh also engage with them on
this as well to see if there's a a
possibility
for them to address the role of
microtubules and so forth in a many
worlds
interpretation sense
and it may be that they do not subscribe
to that so they won't be able to
um
uh they won't be able to uh really have
as much to say about such a thing but as
I say let me try to Ping them back again
if this will work
uh
it's kind of up and died
um
see here
and uh I'll send an email to Roger
hopefully I don't have to start this
again
uh because that might
get rid of the stream as well
um
see if this works
um
Stuart
Stuart I see you on Zoom
and I see an iPhone on Zoom here click
that link I don't know what happened
both you guys are lost
you nod up and down Stuart if you can
hear me
uh let's try this again
I'm gonna try it myself
bear with me
hello
yes
this is annoying
okay I am going to switch to another
live stream
on ecam uh Stuart can you can you see me
or no
Stuart do you hear me
oh I don't have my thing joined Stuart
do you hear me or see me
no I can't hear you hold on a second all
right I'm gonna stop the stream and
we're gonna switch over to uh
to another
um Stuart you hear me
do you have Roger's number to ask him
just to try one more time and then
or
yeah both you guys just got kicked off
I'm gonna go over to
um I'm gonna just stay on zoom and we'll
just do it on live on Zoom but if you
have a phone number to reach him or
okay let me uh I'm gonna quit this
all right everybody so join us over on
the YouTube channel we'll make this a
two-part episode I don't know why this
is not working
but uh join us in just a bit on the
YouTube channel Dr Brian Kitty